hello everyone if you decided to watch
this video you were probably wondering
who is this guy who is mr. Barnes well
Thomas Wilson Barnes is one of the
strongest British players at that time
and he's actually the player with the
best score against Paul Morphy I think
he he won a nine games against eight
games he won eight games against
morphine lost 19 games and this is a
pretty cool game as Paul Morpheus twice
in this game and the mr. Barnes plays f6
on the first move and mr. Barnes was
known for doing this well he wasn't so
strong in the openings but he was the
peculiar moves to confuse his opponents
and but he was a very strong positional
player and Morphy way of actually falls
victim to this but let's see the game
more he plays efore and we have f6 bye
mr. Barnes d4 by morphe e6 we have
Bishop to d3 nice to e7 Bishop to e3 b5
by mr. Barnes tonight to see 3d captures
on e4 Knight captures on e4 and now
Knight to d5 and here morphe might have
I don't know what made more to plate
this next move but I don't think you
realize just how strong mr. Barnes was
and he played nice 2 H 3 and here morphe
is hoping that well since mr. Barnes
played Knight to d5 that he want to
capture this dark square Bishop and III
and the morph it was probably
considering a line like Knight captures
any 3s captures and III and after some
developing move I black like Bishop d7
simply castle and with an open a file
for this rook and this Bishop looking
this h7 bone and the Queen to h5 check
in preparing morph it would be ok here
but after more to play Knight to h3 mr.
Barnes him to play Bishop d7 a nice
developmental move so we have Queen to
h5 check by Murphy and now g6 and more
feet rice Queen to h6
but he gets Bishop to f8 attacking the
Queen so Queen has to go back morphe
plays Queen to h4 and we have Bishop to
g7 morphe castles and
mr. Barnes castles and if you look at
this position okay white is somewhat
better this bone structure black black
bone structure around okay and isn't so
good but it's from black manages to play
f5 and d5 he will be perfectly fine so
we have C 4 by morphe knife captures
only 3f captures only three and now mr.
Barnes pushes f5 kicking that night so
we have a knight to g5 and now h6
kicking the night away from g5 as well
so more free play tonight step 3 and now
mr. Barnes pushes a five and if you look
at the position now well this is
perfectly fine for black black black is
even better in this position so we have
Queen casters on d8
captures on d8 and this point cannot be
captured on e5 because the bishop is
hanging here on d3 so Morphy plays
Bishop to c2 and now simply it captures
on d4 key characters on d4 and bit of
casters on d4 morphia captures the
bishop and rook captures night and mr.
Barnes has won upon ok his pieces are a
bit undeveloped here but well being up
upon and being a quite a good a
traditional player mr. Barnes played
this endgame extremely well but you'll
see multi plays work ste one he wants to
play rook to e7 and mr. Barnes started
this immediate the King to f7 number
three place c5 he prepares Bishop to b3
check and the mr. Barnes plays the
correct move he plays Bishop to e6
stopping this we have the rook a to d1
attacking the rook and Barnes doesn't
capture here but he decides to develop a
piece so Knight to c6 which is a good
move developing the piece preparing to
bring this rookie into the game and also
protecting this rock on d4 so we have
rook captures on d4 Knight captures on
d4 now attacking this bishop on c2 so
more few plays Bishop to a4 and now a
very nice move also pawn to g5 he wants
to limit this knife even further as now
this f4 square is no longer available
for the night so we have a rook to d1
attacking the knight we have a rope to
DA by mr. Barnes a three
and f4 so a very nice pawn chain by mr.
Barnes
morphic plays Knight to f2 and now I
very nice move by mr. Barnes nice - E -
checks he wants to exchange ropes as his
upper bound so this is good for him
we have Kings - f1 and simply wrote
characters on d1 which checks Bishop
captures on d1 and now Knight to g4
Morphy plays King T 1 we have came to f6
bringing the king into the game as you
know King is a very important piece in
the endgame Morphy plays King to d2 and
now another correct move by mr. Barnes
nice to be three check threatening to
capture this pawn and c5 and if he does
this would be completely winning for
black so Morphy has to capture the
Knight Bishop after son b3 and b4
capture son b3 and if we look at the
position now it's well mr. Barnes is
still a pawn up but the more important
than being a pawn up is he has this
bishop over a knight in the endgame and
since the points are on both sides of
the board this is completely winning for
black as the bishop will be able to play
on both sides of the board so we have a
nice eg for check when more feet came to
G so keen to g6 g3 h5 attacking the
knight Knight to f2 King to f5
King to c3 Bishop to g5 King to d4 sees
c6 b 4 we have Bishop to G - G captures
on f4 King captures on f4 now it's
completely winning 2 points against one
on the King side we have a four by
Morphy Bishop to s 194 h4 night to d2
Bishop to e2 nine three four more few
tries a couple more moves you know maybe
maybe mr. Barnes blunders but mr. Barnes
doesn't blender this game and he plays
g4 not to f2 King to f3 attacking the
knight Knight to e4 Bishop to f1 King 35
Bishop to d3 we have a nitrogen 5 check
King to g2 and now Morphy goes for his
pawns on the Queen side but we have King
captures on h2
King to c7 King to g3 preparing to board
eh pawn we have King capture some b7 and
now h3 and in this position Paul Morphy
resigned as this pawn is unstoppable he
would have to capture the pawn and after
G captures on h3 well more more fish
simply too slow to push his own pawn so
a very nice game by mr. Barnes not a lot
of people accomplished such a feat that
they play the f6 on the first move and
the won a game against the one and only
Paul Morphy and this this game should be
a good lesson to you you know if you
play against someone you never never
played before and you play e4 and a
reply what would a move like f6 you know
don't think you don't think you're
playing against the beginner and you
know you haven't won the game yet so
make sure you play good moves and that
moves like Knight to h3 and and such so
yeah that's it for this game I do hope
you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and that's it
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon